grad congratulations again to all the  winners um and now we get to present the  metals and the alternative category can  you okay so these are films that extend  cinematic boundaries and conventions of  expression and they explore in  conventional technical elements and  aesthetics when they work they  challenged the filmmaking experience and  expand the language of cinema these  winning films do just that the winning  films are oscillate by daniel sarah from  the School of Visual Arts in New York a  single vibrating string evolves into  something visually complex intriguing  and beautiful in person by Drew Brown  from the art institute of Jacksonville  Florida shows a transgender teen  struggling to understand who she truly  is and her place in the world